laticia you're known in Spain for quite
delicate roles aren't you in things like
period drama so how was it stepping into
a horror franchise it was like a present
I was really happy and excited and I
just wanted to be ready for it and give
all my best so that's why I started
going to the gym with a personal trainer
to you know become stronger and
physically and also emotionally what
kind of reaction have you had in Spain
to the role because obviously it's so
different for you isn't it yes it was a
great reaction like I didn't know you
knew to kick ass that way you know so I
really liked it
I think it's interesting when directors
give you the opportunity to twist the
image that the industry has about you
exactly and when talking about director
chief worked with Paco Plath and has
directed this film Rex free before how
many you worked on a music video with
him and I think also a fake teaser too
how did the experience compare working
on rack 3 well it was great because the
two experiences we had before they were
really really short like one day of
shooting so we really wanted we knew
that if the day we did a movie together
it was were gonna be a great experience
and actually it was because we really
understand each other worlds and like he
he would tell me just the right things
that I needed to hear and it's a very
physical role as well isn't it I mean
you do your own stunts and how did you
prepare to do that yes I did all my
stunts because I I didn't want any other
woman fighting for my my husband and it
was really fun and two months before the
shooting started I
going to the gym with a personal trainer
and eating our protein and trying to
change my body a little bit and what's
next for you because you've been
directing as well haven't you yes I'm in
the process of editing my third short
film which is genre 2 and I have to
release a film called the last days
which is a post-apocalyptic film that
takes place in person
you